I'm Jean Lukas and on behalf of the
independent feature project West I'd
like to welcome you all to the fourth
annual Independent Spirit Awards
[Applause]
boy that's great this is also the sixth
annual findi Awards that's how we
started and we're so so happy that all
of you can join us here today as we
celebrate the uphill battles and the
hard-won achievements of all of your
colleagues who are today's nominees now
as you may have noticed in your program
the IFP West has respectfully dedicated
the 1989 awards to John Cassavetes
[Applause]
[Applause]
I wanted to write something special and
I really didn't know what to do so I
called Michael Ventura who was a friend
of John Cassavetes and who was kind
enough to share with me a few quotes a
few things that John had said to him and
I just like to briefly share a couple of
them with you I think it's the best
representation of him I like to act in
films I like to shoot him I like to
direct him I like to be around them I
like the feel of it and that's something
I respect a lot it doesn't make any
difference whether it's a crappy film or
a good film
anybody who can make a film I already
love but I feel sorry for them if they
don't put any thoughts in it because
then they missed the boat
that was one of the things he said
another thing was the only thing that
remains constant is the love of what
you're doing and finally after the
onslaught of his illness John Cassavetes
said his life about horror or is it
about the few seconds that you have I
think we're all going to miss those few
seconds we had with John but thank God
we have the legacy of his films and
thank God
the independent feature film movement is
alive and well vital because of the many
under other wonderful filmmakers that
are out there pioneering the same
substance the same thoughts the same
styles that John did and creating all
their own wonderful projects
today's event is a celebration of
everyone of all of you of your
colleagues of your wonderful work of
your struggles of your courage and of
all the benefits that we receive but we
can't put on an event like this without
having friends and one of our best pals
who were with us when this was just a
gleam in our eye they were the first
folks to sponsor us was the Arkansas
Film Commission yes you see you have
these lovely little diamonds in your
plate in front of you now I understand
they actually salt some of their parks
with diamonds there that's that's what I
hear
now I'd like to introduce to you Kristi
Johnson who is the director of the
Arkansas motion picture development
office to greet you today Kristi
[Applause]
Jenny said she's gonna say something
very funny but as we went over it before
there wasn't anything funny about
anything she was going to say we want to
first of all thank you for being here
and thank the independent feature
project West for letting us have the
opportunity to be involved with this
project each year it's it's a wonderful
wonderful event for us an opportunity to
to speak to all of you at one time that
doesn't happen very often and a special
thanks goes to everyone with IP us who
has worked with us and put up with our
timetables and waited on our materials I
would like to have opportunity to meet
each of you individually and hope that I
do have that opportunity when you come
to Arkansas to shoot your next film
please take your Donnell's with you
they have our phone number on it and I
would like to hear from you thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you um I just a few other notes of
thanks here before we proceed we had an
awards committee and a nominating
committee that I mean worked themselves
to the bone they were so generous with
their time and energy and it was a tough
job and they're all listed in your
program and I want to thank them so very
much the volunteers here today many yes
the volunteers here today I mean they've
been here since the wee hours of the
morning making this room happen and and
this event possible and I want to thank
them as well
Klein and Feldman our publicist who yes
[Applause]
who again believed in us and and worked
with us when we were just beginning and
our real vital to the success of this
event for us and I'd also like to
mention that the sound which is
wonderful by the way
was the folks didn't come on board till
after we had our programs printed and I
just want to acknowledge them it's Bob
Raimi and Michele Shanee LeBlanc of
stage lights thank you very much now
everybody's lucky sometimes in their
life and I was real lucky when I Laurie
Fontana's walked in and helped me put on
this event she's the vice chairman of it
and I want to tell you this lady is
tireless she's wonderful and she's
always happy and that makes me thrilled
so Lori wherever you are thank you
[Applause]
now the IFP West has a Board of
Directors that's you know in the
industry in one fashion or another we we
represent a lot of aspects of it and
they all work real hard we're a hands on
board but we were got real smart this
year with our elections and we voted
into office somebody who works even
harder than us and I'd like to introduce
to you the tireless person whose dynamic
and wonderful and we all appreciate so
very much our president Carol Markin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I hope I can equal your introduction
anyway thanks for coming it's really a
great turnout even on Easter weekend a
few weeks ago the IFP West Board of
Directors retreated to the Presbyterian
conference center in Malibu for a
two-day think session for people who
spend a great deal of their lives on the
phone or in meetings
this was not an eagerly anticipated
event believe me
however at the end of those 16 hours we
all agreed that the experience was
invigorating to start things off each of
us was asked to write down on a three by
five card why we became involved with
IFP what we thought the group did best
and what we hoped we could achieve I've
brought along three responses which I'd
like to share with you I believe that
independent feature filmmakers represent
the best hope for innovative and
provocative filmmaking in America and I
would like to play a leadership role in
seeing that that potential is achieved
I like the spirit Awards because they
remind me of the spirit that we all had
when we embarked upon the process they
show me that there is a community of
people out there who continue to
sacrifice in order to see their visions
and their stories on the screen
I hope IFP West can help to reinvigorate
a film industry that is currently
regressive and unimaginative
[Applause]
let me go on that it can create through
its membership a place in a climate that
encourages financing and production of
provocative stimulating films and that
it will continue to broaden the spectrum
of entertainment throughout the world
I'm not going to identify who said these
things but if the members of the board
and the advisory board who are here with
us could raise their hands you can all
take credit for it raise your hands guys
so people can see
[Applause]
all the board members in the advisory
board do put in a lot of labor everybody
else memorize their faces these people
are going to be asking you for money and
your support please be kind to them it's
not just for us it's for you too
today's keynote speaker Oliver Stone
said once at a previous I have fee
Awards is their ceremony that some films
get people thrown into jail he knows
that from experience other movies get
people out of jail we all know that from
experience I invited Randall Dale Adams
here today but he sent his regrets and I
quote ankled Jail conf abs with networks
unquote
but seriously films can make a
difference and some films that have the
potential to make the biggest difference
in our lives aren't being seen Godard
was humorously philosophic about this
issue he once took out a news ad which
said this film has been seen by three
people too enthusiastic but these days
when there are so many ways to see
moving images of all types and from all
eras it's a crime that films on the
cutting edge in terms of content form or
both don't even make it to the art house
let alone the video store the first one
cinema or television IFP West is
committed to trying to help independence
of all elq's find an audience it's a
tough job even for 2,000 committed
people but we're working on it several
members of our board of directors are
now serving on the Rockefeller
Foundation's Task Force on the crisis
and distribution others are looking for
loopholes in the tax laws or within the
agencies we're also investigating ways
to fund screenings of films that no
longer even show in metropolitan areas
or in some college campuses the goal is
to stimulate a little aesthetic debate
perhaps love revolution without it what
will the u.s. be remembered for at the
end of the 20th century McDonald's
rappers pesticides designer baby food
we've chosen a profession that can touch
the heart
and serve as a civilizing influence as
far as I'm concerned it's up to us the
independent thinkers to unite and to
change things there have been examples
throughout history of groups that have
made a difference it doesn't take a lot
of people it just takes a few who have
vision commitment and energy I see a lot
of people have those qualities in this
room I know we can do something if we
work together Thanks
[Applause]
Thank You Carol that was wonderful
the findi Awards which were our very
very first step into awards at all were
created specifically to acknowledge
individuals or organizations who have
been preeminent in their support of the
independent filmmaking community cindy
stands for friends of independence carol
basel men who designed this award as
well as the Independent Spirit Awards
did it with a symbology that was dear to
our hearts as you see we have a
plexiglass pyramid with a shoestring
artfully coiled inside and if you take a
close look at the shoestring there are
little dots that represent sprocket
holes now this is for us representative
of our shoestring budgets but
nonetheless we keep trying to move
upward today to present this award we're
so pleased to have with us john glover
now in high school john glover changed
the scenery but he did it in a way that
got more laughs than any of the actors
and since then he's appeared in a wide
variety of roles on Broadway on
television and in such films as White
Nights Julia masquerade Scrooged and the
chocolate war he received Emmy
nominations for his exceptional
performances in an early Frost and
Nutcracker we're so very pleased to have
John Glover with us to present this
[Applause]
[Applause]
hello the National Coalition of
independent public broadcasting
producers that's quite a mouthful maybe
we should call them the NCO i PB P P the
net this award goes to the National
Coalition of independent public
broadcasting producers who has succeeded
in creating this country's first public
television service dedicated to
broadcasting programs which are
innovative diverse and take creative
risks this independent production
service like channel 4 in the United
Kingdom will allow independence to
reinvent television
Indy's will have the unprecedented
opportunity to produce programs which
break conventional molds and explore the
creative possibilities of the medium
without having to worry about corporate
underwriting or ratings points it's like
television without ratings it's like an
oxymoron I guess like a jumbo shrimp or
a responsible agent
no no but many of us here have eaten the
one and employed the other
for its commitment to independent
excellence in programming we are pleased
to present this findi award to the
National Coalition of independent public
broadcasting producers here to accept
our Laurence Abaddon and Geoffrey
Chester of the National Coalition
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you on behalf of the National
Coalition it is an honor to accept this
year's findi from the independent for
the independent production service in
the early 1980s many believe that it was
time to abandon public broadcasting in
favor of the new technologies cable
Direct broadcast satellite home video
laserdisc etc all of which we were told
then were quote hungry for product close
quote and sure to be a panacea for
independent producers to date that
panacea has not materialized on the
other hand we had a right to access and
funding from Public Broadcasting and so
we continue to make our claim the
creation of England's channel for winner
of last year's findi inspired and
encouraged us to believe that Public
Television might still provide a place
where producers of both nonfiction and
dramatic work could experiment with
innovative program concepts the
coalition's lobbying over two years has
created not only a six million dollar
production service but a new federal
policy encouraging programming that
takes creative risks and that addresses
the needs of unserved and underserved
audiences we hope that out of this new
telecommunications environment will come
fresh ideas for tomorrow's documentaries
features and experimental films and
videotapes
[Applause]
[Music]
that was Larry safranin who's the
executive director of the association of
independent video filmmakers in New York
if you know a ivf they've been really in
the forefront of working around the
country to do something for independence
for over the last ten years I'm Jeff
all over the country our support from
the Hollywood community was particularly
crucial we are indebted to the
International Documentary Association
the caucus of producers writers and
directors visual communications the UCLA
film and television archive and the
independent feature project West we
don't have time to single out the many
and individuals here in LA who were so
helpful to us but I would like to thank
Peter Broderick for his hard work and
Norman Lear for his endorsement of our
efforts the Coalition is particularly
grateful to congressman Henry Waxman and
his staff for their more than a decade
of consistent support I'm also pleased
to tell you that because of the
coalition's work in Congress we were
able to increase by three million
dollars annually the funding which the
Corporation for Public Broadcasting
gives to the five organizations
representing America's minority
communities within public television
until now these organizations were
forced to share a paltry eight hundred
thousand dollars a year the coalition's
success establishing the independent
production service which by the way will
begin this October 18 million dollars
over the next three years is only a
first step in our work to make public
television more committed to the
principles of programming innovation and
diversity we ask for your continued
support
again congratulations and thank you for
being such good friends to independence
and thank you John we have one other
best friend who makes this event
possible and they're not only best
friends to us in this event but in many
other ways they began with us when we
began the Independent Spirit Awards I
I'm going to introduce a gentleman who
will speak to you today on behalf of
this company but I'd also like to
mention Jack Tehan who we call our
knight in shining armor because he has
really worked with us as a partner and
helped us to get the sponsorship that we
needed for this event from the Eastman
Kodak Company and Jack is our friend as
well as a gentleman I'm going to
introduce mr. John McDonough John
McDonough after receiving degrees in
chemistry from Villanova University and
Purdue joined Kodak as a research
analytical chemist this led to several
years as a photographic process engineer
as he concentrated on color motion
picture film he then moved into
marketing where he became director of
product planning for motion picture
films he has since held sales management
positions in various areas of the
country and is presently the manager of
Eastman's marketing and technology I'm
sorry technology Center in Hollywood and
we just think he's the greatest and John
please come and join us
[Applause]
thanks very much Jean
I appreciate the biography I didn't know
how you get all that but I don't
understand why I have to give the speech
in Jack teen gets the commercial anyway
jack team is you know our district sales
manager here and he and his staff are
the people who really work very closely
with independent filmmakers to make my
codex position or supportive position
real when I was asked to give a few
remarks today I was thinking of it in
the context of last year in the year
before when we had we're at 385 North at
Rosalie's you know and it was you know
kind of intimate gathering of people I
said you just get up and talk and when I
got here today it just occurred to me
that we are in the blossom room and the
blossom room is where the first Academy
Awards were held back in 1928 and during
the during the lunch one of my table
mates
Ginny McDowell from time incorporated
said I see you were addressing us and
that all of a sudden that said to me
Jean I guess what happens now instead of
one minute of supportive remarks I
better give one minute of significant
supportive remarks so let me give you
one minute significant supporting marks
and in its in everybody is the way I
feel about the independence of motion
picture movement if you will the you
know that in in the history of this
country and most others the most
significant advances have not been did
not come out of the mainstream they came
out of the edge and and I think that
this is it's so also very true of but
the group were talking to here today and
that is it's the place where you you're
willing to take risk in as a matter of
fact have to take risk it's a part of
the of the business but it's also a part
of what makes the business move and
what's well it's where the real
creativity comes from and I congratulate
you all for continuing to be part of
that movement and I think there's
another significant thing I would like
to say about this and as it is so one
success comes it is so easy to be drawn
into the mainstream and I think one of
the great things about this organization
is that in spite of its success it has
continues to stay out of the mainstream
and in their creative edge and I want to
congratulate you all for that and thank
you very much
[Applause]
we have some great best friends I must
say well now to the Independent Spirit
Awards themselves we are so thrilled
this year to have buck Henry joining us
again yes
[Applause]
this highly respected multi multi
talented man
has written directed and acted in so
many noted plays television shows and
films he created the well-known
television series get smart and
audiences have enjoyed his very unique
performances in TV comedy variety and in
stage plays such as the house of blue
leaves and recently in kingfish which
was at the latc yes fabulous he also
appeared in many movies including The
Man Who Fell to earth eating Raoul the
Graduate first family and heaven can
wait he's written outstanding
screenplays for such films as catch-22
The Graduate what's up doc and first
family which he directed buck also
co-directed Heaven Can Wait with Warren
Beatty is it baby
thank you we're so delighted to
introduce someone who certainly has his
own very special independent style it is
my great privilege to present buck Henry
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
didn't I see you're getting on a Pan Am
flight no never but seriously I'm very
happy to be here again and thank you and
I want to acknowledge how moved I am at
the idea of having a president who's not
afraid to dress like a car Parker
[Applause]
as you know the last few years we we met
at a modest restaurant on La Cienega
Boulevard which like so many of our
independent friends has gone belly-up
and so now we are here in this Castilian
courtyard this somewhat glossy or venue
the beautiful Roosevelt Hotel whose very
name depending on your political
orientation invokes fond memories of
either Brian Keith or ralph bellamy now
the only part of it that worries me is
I'm afraid this means a trend on the
part of the IFP toward ever larger and
more glamorous halls as it works its way
slowly street-by-street year by year
neighborhood by neighborhood toward the
music center of the Shrine Auditorium
where ultimately this once small happy
band will explode into national
primetime prominence with an all-star
show that will combine the feverish
self-promotion of the Emmys the
orgiastic cut stirring of the Oscars and
the slap-happy smarmy Ness of the Golden
Globes
[Applause]
in order to ensure a high semantic level
for today's events I have procured from
the English department at MIT their
latest development in linguistic devices
the jargon Buster specially developed
for award ceremonies this handy
instrument acts as a warning in the
presence of clichés and stereotypes
deranged metaphors and invocations to a
spurious philosophical Authority as as
in the statement for instance I only
hope I am able to grow as an actor and
an artist by tuning my instrument to the
melody of the writers words and the
harmony of the directors megaphone and
thus validate my 23 inspirational years
in Scientology
[Music]
[Applause]
with that in mind I am very happy to
introduce a man who knows what words and
images mean what oh sorry I'm sorry how
badly did he have to go I mean am I
gonna stall for 15 minutes or is it a
quickie
sad to be at the mercy of fine man's
mind and bladder years ago I actually
used to play tennis with Oliver Stone
for a short time because I learned that
it was a contact sport Oliver Stone is
noted particularly for writing out of
his personal experience although if we
extrapolate his persona from such
screenplays as the hand Scarface year of
the Dragon and Conan the Barbarian we
get a picture of a left-handed oriental
drug-crazed troglodyte not true
from his first produced script seizure
which she directed at age 25 on a one
hundred and fifty thousand dollar budget
he went on to write the screenplay for
Midnight Express which won him an Oscar
along with the Writers Guild and Golden
Globe Awards he then wrote a number of
other screenplays which some of which
I've mentioned in passing he directed
Salvador from a script which he co-wrote
with Richard Boyle which won both the
which was nominated by both the Academy
and the Writers Guild the highly
acclaimed platoon was based on his
experience in the US Army's 25th
division the movie as you know received
eight Academy Award nominations and four
Oscars his recent films wall street and
talk radio also received critical
recognition his upcoming born on the
fourth of July is based also on personal
experiences in Vietnam
both Salvador and platoon won several
Independent Spirit Award nominations and
awards including Best Picture Best
Director and Best Screenplay greed is
good
the Academy then duplicated that with
well-deserved awards for platooning for
categories not bad because his bold and
courageous work in films embodies the
independent spirit which we are here to
celebrate today we are honored to have
as our keynote speaker Oliver Stone
[Applause]
[Applause]
Thank You buck gallows here today in
this spirit of the occasion I feel bear
with me if I ramble a bit
there was nothing nicer for me then that
last idle Saturday two years ago at La
Cienega Boulevard when I had my brief 15
seconds of fame when I realized fully
realized that there was a community such
as yourself of independent filmmakers
and there was a bond between us and now
the ranks I I see have grown and I sense
there is no turning back the
breakthrough that occurred around 1985
with that videocassette thing in fact
and I said we're going into a new golden
age and people looked at me like I was
strange and the critics never agreed
with me and I with them but I think in
2020 when people look back and see the
films we made they will realize that
they were good and that like rats and
some genetic maze we each made films
that made the next filmmakers film
better which is what happened in the
1930s there were so many good filmmakers
writers producers actors as there are
today that the pressure may have been
enormous it must have been very
difficult alike to three pictures a year
but by god just by the sheer doing of
them the craft got better and better and
the pictures greater and greater until
it got to be 1939 until it got to be
where it should be people not talking
about it but doing it turning it out
like the medieval builders turned out
cathedrals and the Hindus turned out
those great temples with great story
pictures about gods and devils painting
up there on the walls without
self-consciousness Bravo to all of you
for making the pictures you did this
year for continuing to make them and for
being alive and being here today this
beautiful set of the afternoon and a Los
Angeles April March
but you should have nominated last
temptation because no one else did and
should have because you and I know
whoever made that picture as a soul of
an independent and for that matter
throwing Unbearable Lightness who the
fuck would ever made that picture but
some loony independent mind you know you
know what I'm talking about
[Applause]
so let's not limit the independent ranks
independence is a state of mind
independence walks free everywhere in
the world independence is spirit without
category low budget high budget label
definition stay independent in your
thinking stay independent in your soul
Emerson said and it should be the motto
of this outfit
if a single man plant himself in
dominantly on his instincts and there
abide the huge world will come round to
him and guy I know it's true this life
is most filmmakers say about their own
lives and works has all been but a dream
for me and those little thoughts I had
in my 20s may not have seen the light of
day then and many a bitter soup I drank
but they emerged somehow in my late 30s
and there were the same little thoughts
I always had but now they were shared
and appreciated by others but all along
they were there it just took time and
luck and tenacity to get out and
intersect with the world and find their
place but though I doubted and despaired
I never sold those instincts out I kept
writing them over and over in different
forms and I hope you will do the same
stick to your soul and the hell with
your egos and your soul will take you
where it has to go and you along with it
I just finished a picture a month ago
born the 4th of July it got so hard at
points I kept saying to myself inch my
motherfucking inch became a litany in my
head inch by motherfucking inch it's an
old priceless infantry thing I learned
from Vietnam no matter how hard it gets
survive put your next foot in front of
the other because what other choice
really do you have and if you don't
understand the whole and if you don't
think you're gonna make it relax and die
well because death can't be worse than
this motherfucking pain I'm in forget
the grand plan forget the master course
master scheme forget control just do it
and the rest somehow takes care of
itself the six inches in front of your
face that is the bleak but true basis of
independent cinema inch by inch we must
because we have no other choice
keep looking for humanity in our hearts
for what really matters for why we
survived why we want to go on why is it
we are here to pass on our genes to some
higher level of humanity are we here for
knowledge I keep thinking of the lines
Rutger Hauer mutters as he dies and
Blade Runner I've seen things you people
wouldn't believe attack ships on fire
off the shoulder of Orion all those
moments will be lost in time like tears
in the rain
time to die taking all this knowledge
with him as we each will when our time
comes and what will we do then are we
sperm runners in a genetic relay race
passing on the torch to the next
generation of robo kids with Nintendo
minds and superconductor bodies or is
there is there that lost Faustian
element of love of pure love for for an
athena for wisdom for another person or
persons or planet to refine our capacity
for love is possibly the height of
humanity I don't know I asked some would
criticize the concept of love is
sentimental inadequate to the demands of
a tougher more polluted more
computerized age coming down hard and
fast and cynicism as you recognize is
everywhere in our society in the media
that doesn't really care about a subject
beyond an onion skin surface and a
system of sound bites commercials PR
slogans invented week by week John Gotti
on the cover of People magazine
equivalent in his celebrity hood to any
nuclear or Nobel Prize winning scientist
Oliver North is here Oh George Bush
standing in Boston Harbor and saying
he's for a cleaner environment that week
what difference does it make anymore
we've accepted the lie being lied to so
that our attitude Corson's
no one really cares it's a joke and that
system has rendered us man more and more
insignificant and the artist is
presented as a commercial package but
rarely has he ever listened to or his
dreams are categorized and thus
dismissed by categorization as something
sentimental mocked for simplicity or
destroyed in reviews for doing what what
harm in the
sometimes I look at the movies and I
think they are when all is said and done
and all the ideas come gone discussed
nothing but a parade of faces across
time faces we like hate grow accustomed
to and want to see again year by year
what difference does it really make what
film Melanie Griffith or Mel Gibson do
next I wonder well it does I guess but
you know what I mean if they fall other
similar archetypes will replace them I
think we just want to look at those
faces because we like those faces we
like their behavior their attitude their
parallel human being this I think it
might be that simple Indian Chinese
American movies people want to see faces
and the face is what lights the glow in
the hearts of the audience makes them a
believe again and being human in
traversing the odds and getting up in
the morning and making it through the
day and in being human like that we come
back to the soul strength of cinema
people because man wants to believe in
man woman and woman people in people and
in a world where the systems are
crushing us where our leaders mouth
hypocrisy Zinn lies each day where
politics is a lie what media distorts
the truth or centralization big
government big business is constantly
fuscia stickily pushing gaining each day
on the individual and has wiped out so
much of the human spirit in this century
people are the one recurrent hope we
have that day by day in the Calcutta's
and Manhattan's of the world you get up
and you get through the day inch by
motherfucking inch and by making it you
win if adversity is big and I choose to
believe man is bigger than adversity and
having rambled enough I'll leave you now
with hope in my heart and keep on going
keep on doing it inch by inch thanks
[Applause]
don't you just say what you think Thank
You Oliver
and the family stone this marks the
fourth year of the Independent Spirit
Awards when once again the independent
filmmakers here today have joined
together for the express purpose of
celebrating the struggles and
accomplishments of their colleagues as
usual the nominating committee had a
difficult time finalizing the
nominations slate since there were so
many exceptional independent films from
which to choose so in a very real sense
as I say every year every nominee is a
winner because it's a tremendous victory
to have an independent vision realized
the award itself let's see if I can get
through it this time the award itself
designed by Carol Baugh Suleman
symbolizes the independent spirit of
filmmaking the bronze sculpture features
an abstract bird
the most dangerous kind representing the
independent filmmaker taking flight from
a top a classical column representing
the Hollywood establishment clutched in
its talons our film like shoestrings
symbolizing the shoestring budgets of
these artists it is not true it is not
true that this was designed as an in
scale model from something removed
during allen carr's bypass but seriously
these the ballots were tabulated by rich
ruble s'en Bonnie lemon and Tom Wendler
of Arthur Young and company and the
results were smuggled out of William
Morris and faun holes underwear and so
we will move to the first Awards which
are for Best Cinematography and best
screenplay when Kelly Lynch was a drama
student in New York she got into the
same elevator with the head of the elite
modeling agency oddly enough this is the
same way I started although
I got a felony rap from it she became a
highly successful model but Kelly
quickly returned to her first love
acting and since then she has received
recognition for her performances in
films such as bright lights big city
cocktail and will soon be seen in
Roadhouse and drug store Cao Cao boi
Kelly Lynch
[Applause]
I felt like Harry Dean Stanton made the
move it says here from character actor
to leading man with his highly acclaimed
performance in the film Paris Texas
which won him the British Film Critics
Circle Award and the Palme d'Or Golden
Palm at the Cannes Film Festival but as
far as I'm concerned he is still a
character actor and still the best in
the business he's made more films than I
have time to recount but recently he's
been in pretty-in-pink fool for love mr.
North The Last Temptation of Christ and
twister the Dean of American character
actors Dean Harry Dean Stanton
it's great to have a stand-up comedian
do the speaking I was the only person I
didn't know to be part of this having
made two independent films last year the
cinematographer creatively assembles
images into a new existence his very
special signature evolves as the film
progresses from shot to shot for their
unique expressions of visual excellence
the nominees for best cinematographer
are that's my life she just read and
part of my lines I just have a few lines
for their unique expressions of visual
excellence by the way I can play leads
to so jealous I've known him for years
never liked him we don't want to turn
this into a whole travesty here this is
serious
the Gregory M Cummings Patti rocks
[Applause]
toyomi Chikorita the morons
[Applause]
Robert Richardson talk radio
[Applause]
Tom Richmond Stand and Deliver
[Applause]
spend nyqvist The Unbearable Lightness
of being
[Applause]
and the winner is
Sven Nykvist Unbearable Lightness of
[Applause]
Milton Forman is accepting the award for
Sven Nykvist
[Applause]
I smoke to spend mcfist last night about
these rewards and remember he's a Swede
he's done an American cinematographer
and he asked me first to apologize that
he could not be here tonight today the
reason is he's in the middle of shooting
a film for Woody Allen and they were
supposed to finish this morning
however Woody Allen wants that the
reshooting a Monday morning so he won't
be here until one day evening however he
wanted to express that he wants to give
you a feeling about how he feels about
American independent production as a
sweet first he has the absolute
admiration of the American independent
producers there are souls aunts does
Oliver Stone mr. Mosca for the courage
they had in organizing the financing and
the production of films that are able to
develop material which they
[Music]
with the role of their economic and -
it's logic cannot produce so he feels
very sharply about feeling the highest
admiration for this kind of activity on
the part of American productions then he
asked me to just fall to you what you
have said in the brochure you are
presented here which is that the
integral producers are promoting quality
American independent feature films by
encouraging creativity diversity and
innovation of films produced with an
economy of means and outside of the
major studios he feels that there's a
limitation of the major films and
studios and their ability to support
films of the coin that independent
producers can do and therefore if
there's anything that inspires him to
participate in this kind of activity
it's the real support that the extension
of American film production which not
only is used for American production an
American exhibition but also
particularly for international
exhibition which is the most popular of
all of the viewers by the viewers in the
world of the today so he thanks you and
he appreciates this award
[Applause]
yeah god I'm getting too cynical if we
define annoying as independent
provocative thought then each of our
nominees certainly made an outstanding
point in their individual screenplays
for their exceptional work the nominees
for Best Screenplay are Raymond Menendez
Stand and Deliver
[Applause]
David Burton Morris Chris Mulkey John
Jenkins and Karen Landry for patty rocks
[Applause]
Alan Rudolph and John Bradshaw the
moderns John Patrick Shanley five
corners
John Waters hairspray
and the winner is Raymond Menendez and
Thomas and Thomas
[Applause]
hi I'm Tom musk I wrote it too before
Jaime Escalante was the subject of a
presidential debate and before he was
the subject of a book and before he was
the subject of a play and before he was
the subject of a movie he was the
subject of a screenplay that Ramona and
I wrote and it's ideas and themes were
much bigger than two writers sitting in
a room arguing do we show people on the
first test or the second test so thank
you very much for this award
[Applause]
thank you when we started writing this
screenplay I had two objectives in mind
the first one was to make calculus
thrilling and sexy and we fail miserably
at doing that but the the main goal was
to capture the spirit of Jaime Escalante
a really original American voice and
when a journalist asked mrs. Galante how
accurate was his portrayal he said 90%
so thank you very much
[Applause]
congratulations Thank You Harry Dean
Thank You Kelly two more presenters for
two more Awards Winona Ryder's screen
acting debut was as the lovesick
teenager in the film Lucas after
starring in square dance film audiences
saw her go from the supernatural comedy
beetlejuice
to the nostalgic drama 1969 she's
currently on the soon-to-be-released
Heather's and will be seen later this
year in great balls of fire
not the Warren Beatty autobiography no
writer
Keanu Reeves has often been described as
a young star of tomorrow well that can't
go on forever can it can I'll earn this
reputation thanks to a series of fine
performances in such films as last
year's Independent Spirit Award winning
river's edge permanent record this
year's highly successful Bill & Ted's
Excellent Adventure and the Academy
award-nominated Dangerous Liaisons
liaisons den Chile's can arrays
[Music]
mmm-hmm an exceptional actor in a role
takes what might have been just a
cinematic adventure and transforms it
into a rich and memorable experience for
their inspiring work in American
independent film the nominees for Best
Supporting Actor are Ernest Borgnine
spike of Bensonhurst
Philips Stand and Deliver
devine for hairspray
[Applause]
John mone for the moderns
and John Turturro for five corners
and the winner is
[Applause]
I get a card I had to go to the bathroom
but I didn't dare
[Applause]
well it's a lot of people think I'd like
to thank first of all of course and
they've already been honored Ramon
Menendez and Tom Mollusca not only for
the brilliant script before they're
brilliant guidance throughout making
this picture puddin nerves ran a little
short a lot of times would very much
like to thank my wife Julie cipher who
was an ad on that shoot worked a lot
harder than I did
we met on independent film in Texas when
she was pulling electrical cable through
kalman where I knew I was in love very
much like to think the ensemble of young
actors who portray the students I would
like to thank Jaime Escalante who lives
the courage and the spirit and a love
and the passion that we were able to
capture a little bit of in this film I'd
like to think how her Goldberg Scott
Harrison Steve Levitt from Harrison
Goldberg who encouraged me to take this
picture when I could have made more
money and they could have made more
commissions and last of all I have a
great deal of thanks for mr. edward
james olmos whose brilliant performance
and transformation was not all that
there was to this movie the fact that he
was a leader and a guide and a
touchstone and a supporter and a creator
who brought this character from the
streets of East LA to the screen we will
never ever be able to repay he he gave
me my performance thank you very much
[Applause]
the book for centuries alchemists have
been combine elements trying to make
gold but we all know the secret formula
a gifted actress in the right role for
the most excellent valuable performances
in an American independent film the
nominees Bonnie Bedelia for the prince
of pennsylvania
[Applause]
Roseanna de soto for Stand and Deliver
[Applause]
Debbie Harry for hairspray
[Applause]
in you Madigan principal Sylvania
[Applause]
and how do you sit sorry patty yousa
taki for the wash
[Applause]
Roseanna de soda for standing here
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you very much this is wonderful
I know hi miss gallant is not here today
but I really wish she was because I have
a great deal of respect for this man he
truly has an independent spirit he truly
is an American in the sense of the word
that I admire most I would also like to
thank Tom masca and Ramon Menendez and
PBS for making this film possible it's
an important film it speaks about
independent spirit and that's why we're
all here I was very proud to be a part
of that film thanks a lot
congratulations Lou congratulations for
Santa Thank You Winona keno I stayed at
the Winona keno once in Hawaii Ruben
blades I just like to say that Ruben
blades not the world's deadliest
sandwich as you know what a remarkable
performer incidentally on HBO this month
if you haven't seen dead man out you
better see it it's a incredible film
[Applause]
[Music]
made even more incredible than
incredible by the two guys who star in
it we're coming up now to give the next
two Awards Ruben blades has long been
acknowledged as one of the leading
lights of contemporary Latin music he's
also a Harvard Law School graduate
but opting for performances outside of
the courtroom he now pursues it says
here the twin muses of music and movies
see what I mean
wait a minute that's the ancient Greek
god of the movies celluloid in addition
to his popular albums he's achieved
recognition for his work in fatal Beauty
critical condition Milagro Beanfield
wars recently he appeared in waiting for
Salazar and of course in the critically
acclaimed HBO production dead man out
Ruben blades
[Applause]
Danny Glover as you know no relation to
John a respected actor of many motion
pictures achieves special recognition
from audiences and critics alike for the
roles he created in places in the heart
Silverado and the color purple he
starred in numerous stage productions
television shows including his ace award
performance in Mandela his outstanding
work in Raisin in the Sun and Lonesome
Dove he will soon be seen co-starring in
the sequel to the highly successful
feature Lethal Weapon Danny Glover
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if we like the dictionary defines a
miracle as one an event that appears
unexplainable according to the laws of
nature dan quayle the LA Clippers or
number two an event that inspires
admiring awe in other words the first
feature film which is definitely an
amazing feat especially if it's a film
outstanding quality right for them for
their best first miracle the nominees
are border radio Allison Anders Dean
Lent and Kurt boss
[Applause]
mystic Peter Donald Petrie
[Applause]
Prince of Pennsylvania Ron nice whiner
the chocolate war chief Gordon
the wash Michael you know
[Applause]
I do Danny opens the envelope I know
it's just a winner Donald Petrie
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Wow well I wish my folks could be here I
see
filmmaking very much as a collaborative
art so I really have to share this with
Samuel Goldwyn and Scott Rosenfeld mark
levinson who produced the film a
terrific wonderful young cast including
Julia Roberts a fantastic crew we had
one of those shoots that it didn't rain
when it wasn't supposed to and when we
needed rain a training but a terrific
crew led by Tim sir stead I'd also like
to thank my family for all their
terrific support and and that knowledge
that comes through osmosis that we
showbiz brats seem to get and also my
wife Peggy for going through the bad
times as well as the good thank you all
very much
[Applause]
yeah yeah
[Applause]
okay as the story goes without
hesitation oh I'm sorry
as the story goes that was not Danny
Glover doing mr. an color purple
but John Glover in blackface as the
story goes someone once said to John Liu
GU da surely you agree Monsieur good ah
that films should have a beginning a
middle and an end
without hesitation very promptly good I
replayed yes but not necessarily perhaps
he meant that for a director the
beginning middle and end of a film are a
series of discoveries in terms of the
directors own vision and insight alright
alright I got it again for your unique
direction of an American independent
film the nominees for their your their
unique direction of American independent
film the nominees are
Ramon Mendez
stand and deliver
[Applause]
David bird Morris Patti rocks
[Applause]
Errol Morris the thin blue line
[Applause]
Oliver Stone talk radio
[Applause]
John Waters hairspray
[Applause]
and the winner is mama get slow remain
in this
[Applause]
thank you thank you
this really feels like a reunion more
than an awards ceremony I have many
friends here for Stand and Deliver film
school mates
Michael unum Winona Wally but Richardson
the Salvador table is here and what
comes to mind is an old African proverb
that says a single tree does not make a
forest I like to thank my partner Tom
Oscar producer and co-writer Stand and
Deliver I'd like to thank the actors
other James Olmos Lou Diamond Phillips
Rosana De Soto Andy Garcia and I'd like
to thank my buddies from film school
[Music]
cinematographer Tom Richmond and the
editor and as the Richardson the
composer Craig sailfin who saved my life
during the retest and I'd like to thank
my wife second Seabra who was a customer
on the film and she had to put up with
me on this set and back home
also I'd like to thank American
Playhouse and Warner Brothers especially
a gentleman sitting back there by the
name of Barry Reardon who I think was
the best performance by a distributor
this year
[Applause]
and I like to thank uncle Oliver Stone
the big daddy of the independent
filmmakers for being here I serve as
Oliver assistant director in the film
Salvador and I learn a lot in the film
and Oliver may you continue to make
controversial films inch by
motherfucking each
[Applause]
Thank You Danny Thank You Reuben
incidentally I once had lunch with
jean-luc godard and the the waiter said
perhaps you'd like the salad the main
course and the dessert and jean-luc said
yes but not necessarily in that order
a quickly little stories become myths
I'm very happy to bring forward to dear
old friends
I knew Marty Landau before he explored
other galaxies and I knew Sally Kirkland
before she hired her first press agent
Sally has worked extensively on
television stage and screen he's been
featured in over 25 motion pictures
including the sting the way we were star
is born' her outstanding performance in
the film Anna Anna won her last year's
Independent Spirit Award for Best
Actress it also got her a Best Actress
nomination for the Academy Awards Best
Actress Award from the LA Film Critics
and the Hollywood Foreign Press
Association
following this success Sally has just
completed starring roles in Melanie rose
painted black and cold feet Sally
Kirkland
[Applause]
Marty Landau is a highly respected
veteran actor of the theater television
and over 50 feature films twice as many
as Sally including next month's new
Woody Allen film which he's just
completed for over a quarter of a
century he has been a director and
teacher and his currently executive
director of the Actors Studio a post he
shares with film directors Marc Riedel
and Sydney Pollack among his many awards
and citations Martin Landau has three
Emmy nominations is the recipient of the
Hollywood Foreign Press Golden Globe
Award this year he received an Oscar
nomination for his exceptional
performance in Tucker the man the car
the movie Martin Landau
[Applause]
good thing I can hearing this here
explaining I'm deaf in my left ears to
be on the right side we've got to stop
meeting like this
the human imagination is a priceless
resource and when we see it expressed in
an outstanding performance we share in
the artists creative riches and
ingenuity ah for their exquisite
performance in an American independent
film the nominees are Eric Bogosian
talk radio
Harvey Fierstein torch song trilogy
[Applause]
this smoky patty rocks
edward james olmos stand to deliver
James Woods the boost
[Applause]
and the winner is edward james olmos
stand to deliver
[Applause]
mr. diamond will accept the award
through the moustache look like Eddie I
know that Eddie would be extremely
honored by this award when all of this
talk about awards started after the
release of standing deliver is that he
would he thought about it
and Eddie said the awards don't really
matter the fact is what matters is that
we're here and we're making a
contribution that can be set up Jaime
Escalante and it can be said if edward
james olmos his contribution i can never
really describe to you I know and it
would be very honored especially that
this is an independent award from a man
who into me embodies the independent
spirit thank you
[Applause]
I kind of know the gist of what this is
so I'm not going to read it first of all
I'd like to say most important word that
comes through to me today is gratitude
for being part of this family of
renegades I think that spirit has been
the most important word in my life and
the independent future project reward
for me last year showed that you can go
on and make many many more independent
films I think it's been five since that
Awards so I want to thank these people
that honored me that way last year and
and it's such an honor to pass on the
spirit to these brilliant actresses both
with their nominations and with the
award and there's many theories about
film acting but probably one can say
well an actress who acts in film acting
is acting but an artist who acts in film
making is truly an artist and so for
this artist Jodie Foster five corners
[Music]
[Applause]
Ricki Lake hairspray
[Applause]
no boo McCarthy the wash
[Applause]
Jr Robert's mystic pizza
and Meg Ryan promised land
the winner is Jodie Foster five clients
[Applause]
well when I first read this script
nobody was attached to it I didn't know
anything about it and I said find out
who's doing it and they said Tony bill I
said well I know that guy and I called
him up and said well why don't you give
me a part in this and he said well you
know I guess it's getting off the ground
and and then it sort of did and then
nobody wanted to do it and then all the
young actors said we'll can i play the
part you know the guys we tried to get
for the for my boyfriend said well can I
play the part where I beat everybody up
and the other one would say well it
would be okay if I could star in the
movie if there was more of a starring
vehicle and and then I realized that
finally once we did make the picture and
we made it with all the people we really
wanted to make the picture with I
realized that there were a lot of people
out there making movies to be cool and
impress their friends in the East
Village and a lot of people making
movies to get a good table at a
restaurant and and both even though that
those seem opposed they're not really I
mean there's really not much difference
between either one and the reason I make
movies and I've made movies for 20-some
years is because I love them and because
that's what I do and I'm very grateful
to be able to do what I do which is be
moved and move other people
[Applause]
good going
our final two awards are for Best
Foreign Film and Best Feature and here
to assist me in this presentation
once again Kelly Lynch
[Applause]
[Music]
through their work filmmakers reordered
the fragments of the world into new
patterns of insight I think Peter
Bogdanovich said that in his sleep once
their films become international
ambassadors of the human spirit the
category for best foreign film was
created to honor those films that
express an independent spirit but our
our foreign origination or co-production
and the nominees are a world apart
producer Sarah Radcliffe director Chris
Meng Jie's
[Applause]
Bagdad cafe producers Percy and Eleanor
Adlon director Christiana
[Applause]
brightness producer-director Suleiman
see say
the kitchen Toto producer and Skinner
director Harry Hook
and wings of desire producer Anatole
Dolman director wim wenders
[Applause]
and the winner is wings of desire
VIMS gonna be really thrilled about this
he is in Berlin he wishes he could be
here he's in pre-production on his next
film he sends word that only recently
has he realized that there are angels on
the streets of Los Angeles and he's he's
really thrilled about it and wings of
desire next month is going to be playing
a full year in New York and he is very
proud of that too so he sends you his
best
and please tell them for me that I
thought things of desire was wonderful
just wonderful once a cinematic vision
is conceived a film lurches from crisis
to crisis during its growth and
development throughout those formative
stages the film needs nurturing as well
as the freedom to make its own unique
statement if a film achieves individual
excellence it's often due to the efforts
of a producer who has championed the
collaborative ideals and energies of the
creative team for their very special
examples of cinematic excellence the
nominees for Best Feature are hairspray
producer Rachel Talalay
[Applause]
patty rocks producer Gwen field
[Applause]
Stand and Deliver producer Tom Mosca
the thin blue line producer mark Lipson
[Applause]
and torch song trilogy producer Howard
Gottfried
[Applause]
winner stand and deliver Tom Muscat
[Applause]
we want a lot of awards today but
frankly Stand and Deliver was a film
that's hard to dislike a group of Latino
kids taking a math test twice it pulls
on the heartstrings and I'd like to take
a second and discuss some of the other
films that were nominated for instance
hairspray if I hadn't seen John Waters
pink flamingos a decade ago I probably
wouldn't be here today
[Applause]
paddywhacks was a very controversial
film I thought it took more chances than
any film I saw last year and I thought I
thought to pull them off extremely
successfully my girlfriend has another
view the thin blue line I can't say more
about that feeling got a man out of jail
the fact that torch song trilogy is
being done when people are afraid to go
into public bathrooms I think that's an
incredible tribute to that those people
who made that
[Applause]
without being redundant I'd like to say
we were indeed a independent film Ramona
and I started a long time ago on this we
literally at one time didn't have the
dollar in our pocket to give Jaime
Escalante to option the rights to his
life story we were hard up boys and like
a lot of people who were just doing
whatever he could to keep going
besides thanking Ramon there are a lot
of people for instance we our offices we
literally had our offices in a hallway
and when we'd end to do our deals with
people I see diamond sign over there and
she had just come off a film and I said
Dee can we step out in the street a
moment because that's how we did our
deals on Sunset Avenue and Sunset
Boulevard and frankly it helped us keep
the salaries down so we didn't know what
we were doing but we had people like
Nancy Richardson working far below what
anybody should work for in a film but
they knew that they believed in the film
and they would do it anyway and of
course Edward James Olmos the man came
in early he took a risk you know two
guys called him and flew down to Miami
and knocked on his door and he led us in
and very few actors if more actors were
willing to take that kind of risk we'd
have different films today Tom Richmond
our DP new Ramon for a long time went as
far as moving into the back of Ramon's
house so they could discuss the shots
going for the next day as they drove to
the set and also it got them both there
on time
Who am I missing
Zeca Seabra who did costumes who there's
a lot of research to do a film like this
properly I think where there isn't a lot
of action or narrative so a lot of the
details were done very well by all
concerned but what I think really in the
long run after the film was made what
made Stanley deliver different than a
lot of independent features was the fact
it wasn't marketed as an independent
feature we were not timid in how we
approached getting our film out there we
originally were called walking on water
we knew were never satisfied with the
title and when we sold the picture to
Warner Brothers they weren't satisfied
with the title we weren't afraid to
change it in order we thought to have
reach a broader marketplace whatever you
think about the title we thought it and
had the opportunity to get more people
to see the film and certainly didn't
take away from the film's integrity the
people in marketing I'd like to single
out for a second certainly it's Bob
Hoffman who's been my right-hand man
through most of this film he did a
fabulous job fabulous job he has two
friends they're Lois Ray's and Danny
Harrow who the kind of people that
before anybody heard about this film got
on telephone and said called the
superintendent of schools and Santa Fe
and said we have a film that almost is
in it's about a Latino teacher and the
kids take a math test and you should be
interested we created word-of-mouth we
worked very hard we worked as hard and
distribution on this film as we did in
production that's saying a lot
and also Charlotte G who I don't see
there right now but Charlotte she was a
head of publicity for Warner Brothers
who made this a special case and of
course Barrie Reardon so from the bottom
of my heart thank you for being most
generous and we hope to see you again
some other time
[Applause]
congratulations to all of you thank you
very much once again you all make all
the rest of you possible don't forget
that thank you for putting up with my
nonsense once again and uh perhaps we'll
all see each other in a giant room next
year
[Applause]